esta es la zona cero de las recientes
protestas en civil anka se llama a la
aldea gota gamma que lleva el nombre del
expresidente gotabaya rajapaksa
desde hace más de 100 días los
manifestantes acampan aquí en gal face
en el corazón de colombo
este movimiento está liderado por
jóvenes entre 20 y 30 años como ti zara
al principio no vine aquí para quedarme
solo quería visitar el lugar y cuando vi
los sacrificios de la gente de aquí me
conmovió y decidí quedarme para
ayudarles para ti zara no hay otra forma
de asegurar su futuro que unirse a este
movimiento
si no puedes cumplir tus sueños aquí en
este momento es mejor emigrar a otro
país
y
yo aconsejaría a los jóvenes que se
fueran si tienen los medios pero yo no
puedo ir no tengo dinero
el de acné para decenas de miles de
jóvenes desesperados de sri lanka la
única opción para escapar del aumento de
los precios y del desempleo es abandonar
el país en la oficina de pasaportes de
colombo todos los días hay nuevos
solicitantes llevo tres días esperando
tengo muchas ganas de ir al extranjero
por acá en bus la mayoría de mis amigos
intentan ir a dubai y kuwait para
trabajos de limpieza
en las afueras de colombo nos
encontramos con manu un ingeniero de
software de 26 años gana 400 euros al
mes que era un sueldo alto hasta que
llegó la crisis económica ahora busca
trabajo en singapur
si me voy al extranjero no podré
llevarme a mi familia de inmediato
pero puedo enviarles dinero para que
puedan sobrevivir según los informes del
gobierno más de 320.000 6 land s
solicitaron pasaportes en los últimos
seis meses mientras que en 2020 sólo
fueron 200.000